Turkish prosecutors have published more
details about the indictment of several
Saudi nationals for the murder of
journalist Jamal khashoggi it includes
pictures and information about the
alleged perpetrators and testimony from
Turkish employees working at the Saudi
consulate in Istanbul mr. [ __ ] a critic
of sati of Saudi rulers was killed
inside the consulate building in October
2018 cinema Kosala points us live from
Istanbul so said um how do these details
change the overall picture about what we
know happened well some so far what has
been revealed about democritus murder
case was revealed and there are some new
information on the indictment which are
the new pictures of Jamal keshavjee and
his fiance a week before being killed in
the Saudi consulate in Istanbul on
October 2 he was he went to the
consulate on September 28th to initiate
his marriage paperwork with his fiance
so the picture of that day is also on
the record plus as everybody would
remember the Miccosukee one of the
perpetrators
- Carter Marcus you've just closed and
got out with his clothes acting as if he
was keshavjee as a body double there are
some extra pictures of that person who
went to Sultan Ahmed after leaving the
consulate after the murder and going to
a restaurant going to the toilet and
then shaving his beard so in the same
place he has a picture entering with a
beard and exiting without a bit which is
which is a proof that he was involved in
the murder and the passport IDs are
revealed also the phone trafficking of
the perpetrators are revealed as well so
how does this impact the judicial
process then see them
well summer this indictment was prepared
early Marjan in March and on April 11 it
was accepted by the court so the court
proceeding has been launched and it is
it is an ongoing process in Turkey
turkey has extra that it has asked for
extradition of those 20 suspects
including al-ansari the intelligence
chief and so delicate and who's the
special aide of the crown prince who are
very close to the Crown Prince Mohammed
bin Salman but there is another there is
another ongoing judicial process in
Saudi Arabia a country that rejects to
extradite those people but here the
court proceeding will continue and the
company the person will complain who
filed the complaint was Democritus
fiance
her teacher as his family members
avoided filing a complaint in Saudi
Arabia probably because of the threats
and fear no I believe it I thank so much
silica so Allah